it's Friday and that means it's time for
Joe just doesn't know when to let it go
AOC sporting a new accent and video that
will make our male viewers cringe
joining us all with all the details
arena Royal Fox News contributor New
York Times bestselling author of number
three in a series well while there the
amulet of power all right Raymond Joe
Biden spoke publicly he was at the
Hinkley Hilton today I understand
a lovely reference he was speaking at
the International Brotherhood of
Electrical Workers in DC the president
of that Union Lonnie Stevenson
introduced the former veep with a hug I
just want you to know I had permission
to hug Lonnie all those kids you want to
come up on the stage you can come up
it's okay by the way he gave me
permission of touching my now Laura some
commentators are absolutely furious
about what Biden that Biden would dare
to joke about the hug and sniff gate
look at this
it was joking around on stage but it
just wasn't funny making light of it
sort of I don't know leaves me
scratching my head the fact that he
joked about it today is a problem he
says he gets it he doesn't get it I
suspect a lot of other people especially
the women involved here are gonna find
offensive enough to have a sense of
humor he's of a different generation I
agree with the left hire actually lost
any not aware there are people on the
right and also have the torches and
nooses out for Joe Biden
my grandfather whom you met ran a
restaurant for years he would hug and
touch and grab people by the fence of a
if you ever in my life but he was being
affectionate it wasn't creepy it wasn't
lecherous it was his generation in their
way of being I think we should all walk
around with bubble wrap and we should
just we should walk around like to hello
Howard
you later did you see the New York Times
said there should be 18 inches between
intimates and three to four inches I
mean I'd have to be 12 feet away from
you to act hi hello Laura what you're in
my aura space is ridiculous anyway I've
got to get to this meanwhile over at
Reverend owls na n convention today your
favorite Congress that Nancy Pelosi is
known to man National Action Network
Alexandria Acacio Cortez was trying out
a new accent mmm
the fights been long y'all this is what
organizing looks like look this is what
building power looks like I'm proud to
be a bartender ain't nothing wrong with
that well there may be something wrong
with that Oh si si seems like she's
trying out this new African American
southern esque accent now she's gotten a
lot of blowback and it forced her to
respond on Twitter she wrote I'm from
the Bronx I act and talk like it
especially when I'm fired up and
especially when a minute I think it but
that that doesn't exactly sound like
Queens the Bronx the Bronx and queens
okay but I'm not getting that this ain't
I know a way to remind your minds of us
of weed I know way tired I don't feel no
ways tired
[Applause]
[Music]
from where I started from nobody told me
that the road would be easy
somebody should remind these women all
african-americans are not beneath the
mason-dixon line and when your every
time you're in front of an
african-american audience you don't have
to try to affect this very odd be
yourself just be your suffers this is
the way we talked her ID please we've
been playing sound bytes from her first
well remember when she said this Lord on
a radio show huh what's something that
you always carry with you how does us
really know that's what I want you to
know people are gonna see this day okay
she's paint her in the black people okay
is it working is it working yeah that is
the revelatory line this is obvious
pandering to the crowd you're in front
of it she was treated like a rock star
and overused phrase but when she walked
in she got more applause than hand flail
er baito
Kamala Harris does that thing when she
walks on the stage she starts laughing
yeah no one's made a joke
she laughs through everything but aoc
walks out it was they were she owned
that house she did she did a good job at
that speech before we run out of time
this next bit of video could really be
called Friday Follies now this poor guy
he's a Florida lumberjack he was
removing a tree when things went very
wrong it's a reminder that when you cut
down a tree mind where you're standing
men you've been warned
[Music]
are y'all right we have to say he's he's
alright but you know it begs a question
when a prostate falls in the forest can
it get up again that's horrible
I would I hurt when I saw that now I was
thinking about Joe Biden yeah thinking
through the pain what we really perhaps
need are pre hug consent decrees this
was in our Lumbridge I've been doing
these pre hug consent decrees where in
case of a funeral or a school event
graduation or Joe Biden's house you get
a pre consent to hug people I've been
getting people to sign them all day long
and here at Fox it oh you have another
thank you oh thank you I don't need you
to sign it I've got plenty of oh so you
were out you were allowed to hug where I
have the consent form oh I'm gonna go
get Tucker to sign one next by Laura I
want one